وعلى الاقل من كياف عماد ابو الربه رئيس
المركز الاوكرانيا الحوار والتواصل استاذ
عماد اهلا وسهلا بك على نبدا من حيث انتهى
هذا التقرير الذي بعث في اثناء عن جمله من
الاقلات والاستقالات في صفوف عدد من
المسؤولين الحكوميين في كنا قد تحدث عن
هذه التغييرات التي ربما لها علاقه مباشره
ما بما يجري على الجبهات اي طبيعات لهكذا
اقالات واستقالات على سير الامور والاوضاع
تحياتي لكم الاستاذ المشاهدين للاسف اغلب
الدول يوجد فيها فستعد هناك ناس من لديه
نزعت الخير ونزعه الشر وبالتاكيد يعني
اوكرانيا كباقي الدول يوجد ربما بعض
الموظفين سواء يعني تسار حولهم شبهه او
ثبت شيء من الفساد الشيء الطبيعي ان يكون
هناك محاسبه وفصل وعزل وتغيير في الوظائف
ومحاكمات في حاله وجودها هذه ظاهره صحيه
سبق لي قبل سنه ونصف ان التقيت رئيس هيئه
مكافحه الفساد في اوكرانيا السيد
وكان حديثنا حول ضمان يعني الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه في اوكرانيا وحمايتها وكان هناك
خطه استراتيجيه واضحه لاوكرانيا في محاسبه
اي مسؤول فيه اي دلائل على هذا الفساد
للعلم للان همم وزير الدفاع همم وزير
الدفاع اليوم على صفحته الرسميه ان هناك
همم معلومات خاطئه
كل الاحوال همم عزل همم او استقاله النائب
هي خطوه اولى للتاكيد على عدم تغطيه
الحكومه على اي ممارسات او تصرفات او فساد
لدى موظفينها ولكن سيكون هناك محاكمات
قادمه للجميع وعلى ضوئها سيتم معرفه من
المذنب او من اثيرت فقط حوله شبهات طيب
استاذ عماد ننتقل ربما الى الوضع الميداني
هناك حديث عن تكثيف فداء القصف في محيط
زبوريجيا وايضا في الجبهات الشرقيه
والجنوبيه اللي اوكرانيا ما الاصداره التي
ربما تداول تم تداولها في الاوسط السياسيه
في اكياس اذا ما يحصل ميدانيه
حقيقه يعني الكل يتابع المنطقه الجبهات
اوكرانيا تاكيدا على حرصها على الدفاع عن
وحده سياده اراضيها كثفت جهود التعبئه
والتي سيتم على ضوئها امداد كل المناطق
الساخنه وهذه الجبهات تحديدا خلص زباروجيه
دانيسك لوجان
دي مزيد من القوات الاوكرانيه هناك حقيقه
حرب شرسه جدا يزيد يوما بعد يوم ولكن تم
رصد اوكراني للقوات الروسيه ان اغلب من
يقاتل فيها هم همم من تم تعبئهم حديثا اي
انهم ليسوا الجنود الحرفيين النظاميين
الذين ربما تاخر اشراقهم روسيا لمواجهه
اكبر نهايه هذا الشتاء
عماد ابو رئيس المركز الاخرى للحوار
والتواصل حتى تنام من